reportedly written in just six days by
John Hughes Ferris Bueller's Day Off
captures a single magical day in the
life of a high schooler who understands
well life moves pretty fast if you don't
stop and look around once in a while you
could miss it
Ferris outsmarts his parents and his
principal steals a classic car gets the
girl gives his best friend's
self-confidence diamonds in a fancy
restaurant takes in a baseball game and
even sings a Beatles song on a parade
float
they all adore it they think he's a
righteous dude so why is it that we only
ever got that single movie here are some
reasons why we never got to see of
Ferris Bueller sequel Bueller Bueller
Bueller it didn't need one director John
Hughes and star Matthew Broderick stayed
in touch for a few years after filming
wrapped on Ferris Bueller's Day Off and
talked about ideas for a sequel
according to Hughes in those proposed
movies Ferris would quote be in college
or at his first job and the same kind of
things would happen again the two
ultimately decided that a sequel like
that would basically be a lame rehash
because the original movie was quote
about a singular time in your life
incredible one of the worst performances
of my career and they never doubted it
for a second John Hughes moved on he was
created a string of classic teen movies
including The Breakfast Club
pretty-in-pink
and sixteen Candles and Ferris Bueller's
Day Off was just about the last one
after Bueller he was only made one more
teen movie in the 80s 1987 some kind of
wonderful then he shifted a family fare
like Uncle Buck and home alone and more
grown-up films such as she's having a
baby and planes trains and automobiles
there's your other hand to cling to
pillows those are pillows
Bizzy Broderick Matthew Broderick was
one of the biggest stars of the late 80s
and a big part of that was because of
his role in Ferris Bueller's Day Off in
the five years afterwards
Broderick starred in an eclectic bunch
of movies from contemporary dramas like
torch song trilogy and Project X to
comedies like family business and the
freshmen to period pictures like Biloxi
blues and the oscar-winning civil war
epic glory with all that on his plate
Robert just didn't have time to make a
sequel Hughes didn't dig sequels
there aren't many sequels in the Hughes
filmography while a screenplay for the
first vacation movies based on a true
story he wrote up for National Lampoon
he skipped having anything to do with
European vacation though he did return
to write Christmas vacation that's the
only sequel Hughes ever worked on he
reportedly toured with a follow-up to
The Breakfast Club for years which would
have presumably been called the Lunch
Bunch but could never come up with a
legitimate reason to get those five
characters back into the same room again
similarly he just couldn't conceive a
worthy Ferris Bueller sequel you're
still here it's over go home
second movies second thoughts in spite
of a sequel aversion he was still mapped
out his ideas for Ferris Bueller too he
shared some of them with Geoffrey Jones
who played evil principal Rooney at a
huge tribute event after the directors
death in 2009 Jones claimed Hughes had
told him some of his ideas for Bueller
too but all Jones would say was that it
was supposed to be set in Hawaii and
that it fell apart because Broderick
ultimately wasn't interested in
reprising his role what about a sequel
series in the fall of 1990 NBC debuted a
single-camera sitcom called Ferris
Bueller which operated under the odd
conceit that the show depicted the
real-life characters in which the movie
version of Ferris Bueller's Day Off was
based on and they hated the movie this
is television this is real the show
which was pretty much a standard high
school sitcom notable only for the
participation of a young Jennifer
Aniston as Buehler sister Jeannie didn't
attract much of an audience and was
cancelled halfway through the 1992 91 TV
season not to worry Cameron
I fixed it
there were two sequels sort of though
there was no full-length sequel Matthew
Broderick did sort of reprise his role
as Ferris Bueller on two occasions and
John Hughes 1988 relationship comedy
she's having a baby the end credits roll
is a rapid-fire montage of celebrities
throw out their ideas for what Kevin
Bacon and Elizabeth McGovern's character
should name their new baby among the
cameos is Matthew Broderick clearly in
character as Ferris Bueller Jim and in
2012
Broderick returned again for a two and a
half minute Honda Super Bowl commercial
which features numerous knobs for the
movie he may not have technically been
playing Ferris Bueller but this could be
the closest we ever get to a sequel he
bought it how can I handle work on a day
like today fan script in 2011 an amateur
screenwriter named Rick rapier went
viral when he released the first 12
pages of a Ferris Bueller sequel script
he'd written the plot Ferris Bueller is
now 40 years old and is a motivational
speaker a la Tony Robbins but he's
incredibly overworked so with his
business manager Cameron fry he takes a
day off it couldn't gain much traction
in Hollywood however rapier hadn't been
hired by anyone to write the script or
even asked the script was never
purchased in rapiers 15 minutes of
internet fame were up I changed my mind
I want you on in front of the school
with her I'd like to have a few words
with you by God maybe they'll do one
someday
Alan Rock who played Ferris his best
friend Cameron has spoken about a loose
idea for revisiting the movies
characters in the distant future the
plot Cameron still a sad sack at seventy
commits himself to a nursing home even
though he's in relatively good health
his old friend Ferris gets wind of it
bust him out and the two old men have a
blast going into the city hitting a
strip club etc at the end Cameron dies
with Ferris Bueller thirty years in the
past and both ruck and Broderick in
their 50s now that means this Ferris
Bueller returns could hit theaters
sometime around 2036 I said it before
and I'll say it again life moves pretty
fast you don't stop and look around once
in a while you could miss it thanks for
watching click the looper icon subscribe
to our youtube channel plus check out
all this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]